i've never spoken to uh this guy but uh
i sure
love his work i love his love for
baseball
and i love how he takes you inside the
game in a way that
few can or do he is john boy of john boy
media here on the rich housing
here on the rich eisen show how are you
john boy i'm doing well thank you guys
very much for having me
opening day i just took a stroll around
the stadium
it's cold but there's a lot of energy so
uh i'm excited the stadium is in
either one in the bronx new york correct
is what you're talking about
yeah our office is two blocks away so we
just walked over
took it in saw ourselves on the
billboard smiled a little and then now
we're in the warmth of our office again
okay very good cold day garrett cole
out on the mound i mean so who who
who was your guy growing up who was it
how old are you by the way
let's start with that i'm 32. okay so i
i grew up in the jeter
it was uh you know watch him play and
also listen to his interviews and
how he handles himself was you know kind
of i think my dad had it easy he was
like just be like that guy
he's the example so i i very much grew
up as a little kid
idolizing derek jeter and then so so
how so i'm trying to do the math in my
head here
uh because i was seven years old
when catfish hunter arrived and
um chambliss went yard in the 76 pennant
and the yankees got wiped out by the big
red machine but i was eight years old
when reggie arrived and that was a game
changer for me and i'm a die-hard yankee
fan ever since but mattingly and reggie
are my guys
so you know i was i was seven and 96 and
then eight
you know moving on so you know we saw
championships at the same age they're
very young
that's about it so uh and then um
how come you're so into baseball and not
other sports
because that is a question that i think
is legit
uh john boy i think it's a legit
question certainly because baseball is
trying to get people
your age to do what you're doing
uh which is talk baseball as much as
possible
yeah i actually love the pace of
baseball um
i think the action can be increased so
like i i do think it
it the the amount of action has slowed
down in the later years
but i enjoy the pace i enjoy being able
to to talk to the person in the seat
next to you
and play the guessing game of what would
you call here what would you throw here
well we just threw two curveballs so now
we should probably go a high fast pawn
all the intricacies and the mental part
of it i love that and i mean
i like how you know it's all still and
then everything can explode in
any moment and the baited breath when
the pitch is on the way to the battery
you know all that stuff that
all the baseball historians can talk
about in flowery language and
romanticize i that's gospel to me i love
it so
i grew up my dad played baseball in
college and then obviously
the yankees were were great as i was a
kid
my family moved around like every two
years of my life
and our sticking point was you know we
were a yankee family we liked yankee
games when we lived in
we lived in australia for a little bit
we lived in illinois and my mom would
record the
all the playoff games on vhs we would
eat dinner as a family
then we would watch the game together
afterwards it was a different time zone
uh in australia so it was kind of uh
you know it's a family thing for me it's
a sticking point it's something that
when we talked to our friends back east
when we were moving around it was a
conversational point and
then when i finally moved back here and
i got to be into the thick of it again
and have the everyday conversations i
was in heaven
so where'd you get the name john boy
oh that's a bad story so that that comes
from a
autocorrect my buddy's phone auto
corrected jimmy
yes to johnny when we were in college
and then my buddy now was my
partner and all of this jake he would
just change
change it from john john boy johnny john
[Music]
it was like a running joke for maybe two
weeks
but in those two weeks i changed all my
socials because i was applying for real
jobs at the end of college
to john boy and and now here we are and
now here you are and you you first
started
uh with a podcast at age 17. is that a
true story
2017. so when was your first time that
you when you did that
2017 was when we started uh talking
yanks which was our first podcast
it was just a hobby that i was doing it
after work on the side
i was living uh with my with my
girlfriend at her parents house
and i was just desperate to talk to
anyone about the yankees and
and you know live tweet every game and
all that so once the the following grew
a little bit i started a podcast and uh
thankfully some people were tuning in
they had no doubt about that and before
you know i have so many questions about
you know your ascent before we actually
settle into talking
baseball with you uh john boy of john
boy media here
on the rich eisen show um have you ever
gotten a call from major league baseball
to say knock it off
you're using our material did that ever
happen with you
no no that that hasn't happened we
actually i met up with someone
at some event that was from mlb social
team and
they were incredibly friendly because i
didn't know and i didn't i'm not i don't
want to ruffle feathers i'd rather work
with them than against them
and i didn't know how they felt and
they're like oh we got to work with you
and i was like yeah i'd love to
you know work together in some way and
have the same goal and you're like yeah
if we're not working with you like
that's a shame
so that was the first step and then i
never heard back and then and then
last year we got some calls and tried to
figure out some ways that we could work
together but
i don't think we've ever landed on a
specific plan so we've never really
partnered anything but
as far as i know that they're not upset
with what i'm doing
uh might be happy about it and i've
never gotten any complaints
i've helped us out a decent amount well
i'm pleased to hear that because they
should
they should uh want your material
to be out there because it's it's to me
when you put out a video
and you're breaking something down um
you know and you're noticing something
that i i
didn't pick up because you know i'm i'm
you know either i'd have the sound up or
something like that
um i'm i'm tuned in i'm i'm locked in so
even when you're you're showing how the
astros
went through with banging trash cans at
what time and how
pitchers reacted and how they were
clearly upset about it because they knew
it was happening at the time
and we as fans didn't weren't in on it
just yet
i mean baseball never said to you knock
it off
never not once not once no i i've never
had anyone reach out
and i'm sure there are people that
dislike it that's only human nature but
i've never had a player or anyone reach
out
and say they weren't a fan of what we
were doing i mean i'm
i'm not saying they don't exist they
just have not spoken up and
and let me know so it's all been
positive on our end and the savages in
the box
i mean that that that obviously the
video where you
uh broke down how uh gardner was bashing
his bat
on uh on the top of the dugout and aaron
boone was arguing with the
home plate umpire and you were picking
up on it i mean have you ever spoken to
any of those yankees
since then john boy about all that yeah
with that i was at an event
um cece sabathia's gala in 2019
aaron boone it was pretty close to right
after that happened and
the yankees had made some statements
that they weren't thrilled and they
wanted to look into how to stop
audio getting leaked and i understood
what they were saying and why they were
saying it
so booney came up to me and he just kind
of nudged me from behind
he said you're funny and i said oh okay
so you're not mad no i don't care at all
it was awesome
and then i've had you know i've had
players from multiple teams
they'll dm me and say hey do this one
our bench coach got injected it's
hilarious
or hey do this one so no i i even that
and i was happy about that i mean you
know it blew up
bone spot but only in a really positive
way i think it helped his image more
than anything it was hilarious it was
funny and
even some umpires were like well he said
what he said but he did it with
compassion in a way
i didn't think he would be mad about it
and i was glad to find out he wasn't
john boy of john boy media here on the
rich eisen show
let's get into it it's it's the dodgers
world and we're all paying rent
this year what do you think yep yep
their their b team is just as good as a
lot of teams a teams they have
i mean they're they added mookie bets
last year and now they add trevor bauer
this year
and they're still getting better they
bring turner back who is just
a postseason nut job but his post season
numbers are amazing so
yeah i think it's dodger's world i think
some stuff's gonna have to go really
wrong for them i'd be i'd be really
surprised if they're not in the world
series again
it's just amazing the red sox just
couldn't figure it out with bets and i
know that you know obviously talking
amongst two yankee fans it's like the
small violin playing but
i i i it it still boggles the mind john
boy that that
that that the homegrown star
needed to go to los angeles to be widely
respected enough
i just it it i i don't understand it
i still i'll never understand it you
know i don't understand it
at all it doesn't make sense i don't
even think the return they got was that
great and that's why it's
it's cool to see what the padres have
done with tatis and say
hey you know we got a lot of fans coming
to padre's world right now
because we're growing because we're
getting fun well here's some loyalty for
you he's not going to leave for a decade
imagine if the indians did that with
lindor the
red sox did that with mookie beth
sometimes
you know letting the fans know and and
giving the fans that respect
like yeah he's going to be here forever
because he's amazing we love him and you
guys love them like
it's just kind of a slap in the face to
not even try and to trade them
not even to like play the season out and
see what you can get
so you know we're we're on all across
southern california
thanks to uh the mightier 1090 in
southern california let's
linger on the padres a little bit you
don't think the padres might be able to
you know seven-game series this bad boy
against the dodgers you don't think that
that could be a possibility
when it's all said and done or yeah i've
been running into this uh
this dumb take i keep saying where i
think the padres have a better chance of
winning the world series than they do
their division
i don't think they can beat the dodgers
in a 162
race to most wins but in a crapshoot
playoff
series maybe the braves beat the dodgers
and then the padres and the braves meet
up or
or maybe someone else takes care of the
dodgers or maybe they beat him in a
seven game set because anything can
happen there
uh but i'd still put my money on the
dodgers we'll see when we get there
i like the padres pitching i wish
clevenger didn't get hurt i wonder if
they'd still pick up snell
and darvish um but i i like i like what
the padres have done that's what you
need to do to try and compete with the
dodgers
well i mean and i'm sure in new york
city across town
mets fans with lindor uh you know with a
10-year contract extension
300 and some odd million dollars um
he's going to provide the spark that you
know uh at least the grom
maybe degrom loses what uh three to two
now instead of two to one but uh i i i
i don't i don't unless you think this
could be some sort
of with uh with alonso they can actually
put something together
in in the nl east what do you think
we'll
we'll see the analyst is pretty fun i
keep saying that
one of the mets phillies and nationals
is gonna just
stink and i don't know how and i don't
know who
but i but one of those guys is going to
surprise us in the wrong way
and then the two others will probably be
as good as we think they should be
the mets are interesting and it really
kind of just comes down to a vibe thing
and
they have the bats i don't like their
pitching to start the season but if
carrasco and cindergard come back then i
like their pitching a lot
and those guys should come back and be
healthy but we'll see it's always been
bullpen
and uh their defense isn't great they
got a lot of bats but they got a lot of
guys playing seemingly
not there a few more minutes left with
john boyer position john
a few more minutes left with john boyer
john boy media here on the rich eisen
show on opening day what about the
american league
who do you like in the in the american
league this year
well i'll say the yankees okay and uh
you know i can't not say the yankees
well why is that i mean
you know why why why why you know
because you know
cole and then obviously you know um
adding kluber would be something um
one if if the kluber of his cy young uh
years shows up um yeah i'm actually i'm
pretty skeptical on kluber but
but i like i like um i like the yankees
in 162.
i like i think they have enough pitching
depth with montgomery and
uh hermann and tyon and kluber and even
davey garcia
and you know the yank this yankees team
won 103 games in 2019 with
while also having the most injuries any
teams had in the history of baseball so
i like them for the regular seasons uh
regular season
it's just when they get to the playoffs
who's going to be the number two behind
coal and we're going to need one of
those pitchers that i just named to step
up and take that role otherwise i think
they're in for a scary repeat of the
last three years
but i mean the lineup today is so crazy
if these guys can stay healthy and those
are the magical
words uh the yankees are the best team
in the al and i think every
every site has them listed that way i i
hope the white sox take the jump
and i think they added some nice pieces
to their team i hope the rays are awful
because i'm a yankees fan uh and i also
don't like the way they do things even
though it works
uh and then uh you know the west coast
is kind of sloppier than i think
people realize the asterisk took a step
back i think the aids took a step back
and then the mariners and angels and
rangers
aren't going to do anything big and so
uh
lingering a little bit on the yankees
before i let you go sir
um is judge an mvp this year is this the
year is this finally the year
for him what do you think who's the mvp
if he's if he's on the field
yeah every time he's healthy his numbers
are great and
uh he's never not performed when he's on
the field it's just a matter of staying
on the field so
let's get through april and the cold
weather and see how see how long he can
last but
yeah if you look at his if you look at
his stats when healthy the last three
years he's a top
ten top five player in almost every stat
that could matter
it's just a matter of being able to stay
on the field so there were some
fluke ones early on his career but last
year is a lot of soft tissue and
the injury prone one so i hope so i
think he's really
really special to watch i mean he's got
an arm he can he's faster than you think
i don't think people realize that he's a
plus defender just because of his size
but he is and that's really fun and then
what's the date over under uh i'll give
you over under
uh may 1st of what's wrong with gary
sanchez you take the over the under
what do you got for me i think i well
listen i've been a gary apologist for a
long time it's pretty tough time
for us gary apologists right now i think
his i think the rest of his career
here's the hottest take i think the rest
of his careers
is made this april because we've seen
him have bad starts he can't get himself
out of those
uh so i if he has a good april i think
he'll i think he'll have a good year if
he has a bad april i think he'll have a
bad year so
i think i think may 1st is the great
over under
of one we know and if he has a bad year
i think his career is
is drastically i think he's a backup
meddling around or dhing every other day
for some team but
i will root for gary it's opening day so
we got to be positive and happy
he's going to be great okay um and so
last one for you predict for for me the
mvps and cy young's
and then you know we'll put it in there
we'll put it in the freezer and take it
out
unless you're off and then we'll just
act like this didn't happen it is sports
talk radio so
what do you think all right i'll i'll
give the grom the cy young
again uh i like that and i i like that
you know mets fans can just still
act like that's a world series
championship and they'll cheer for that
um instead of winning the world series
and they'll be like yeah but we got the
grom
okay the angels have trout so we'll give
trout the mvp okay
uh in the al as well all right and then
we need an a.s
let's go with by dude lucas chialito
he's uh i've got a podcast on my network
so i'm rooting for him
and he's not in the american league east
so he won't do much damage against the
yankees
and i think he's primed to take a step
up he's getting the
the ball in opening day here and then
what why need a national league mvp yes
you do
you do i think aaron auto would be fun i
think that the cardinals going out and
making that move and and getting
uh paid on it and having it be rewarded
and helping them when the division will
be a cool storyline for baseball
and a little you know more screw you to
the rockies which i think they deserve
john boye thanks for the call everyone
can get your media
where for anybody wants to know because
you have and how many podcasts do you
have now and
and shows including chris rose my
colleague from nfl
network john boyce we have we got a ton
i think we i think we're up to like 40
shows or
or 30 shows there's a lot on that where
chris rose has a show
trevor poop who just uh flew in today to
sit with us he's got
a couple shows on network sequence he
says that you guys were flight buddies
one time on twitter
told me to tell you that's the thing i
tell you i that's a
that's a fact tell him i said hello too
i enjoyed uh chatting with him
he's he's terrific i follow him on
twitter too he's terrific
he yeah he's been great so if you go to
johnboymedia.com it's got a lot of our
properties and
whatever social media platform you're on
if you search onboard media you'll be
able to find us
well look uh john boy uh i appreciate
the call let's do this as regular as
you'd like
uh i like i said i appreciate your takes
i appreciate the way that you
uh the way that you uh put your your
media and your content together
um and i appreciate the time here on
opening day enjoy it
yeah but happy to come back whenever
thank you very much for having me and my
voicemail did that play on your did that
work
my voicemail it was beautiful it was
beautiful okay very good
take care of yourself thanks for the
call that's john boy of john boy media
right here on the rich eisen show he had
a
he did a uh a voicemail only show
where he has people leave voicemails
with their opinions about the yankees
and he just plays the voicemails
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here